[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a diario de copas el
programa de france 24 en español en el
que analizamos la actualidad de la copa
américa y la eurocopa a continuación los
titulares
celebración argentina la selección de
argentina dirigida por el lionel scaloni
venció a brasil en la final para
quedarse con el trofeo de la presente
edición de la copa américa el resultado
significó el primer título para lionel
messi con la selección absoluta
albiceleste
figuras emergentes a pesar de un
contexto negativo la copa américa dejó
ver nuevas figuras en algunos equipos
del continente analizamos la
competitividad del torneo y los
jugadores que destacaron a lo largo de
este mes
en el podio la selección de colombia
superó a perú y se quedó con el tercer
puesto de la presente edición de la copa
américa los cafeteros no ocupaban el
podio de la competición de este 2016
cuando finalizaron con la medalla de
bronce en la copa américa centenario
como ha sido habitual en cada una de
nuestras emisiones contamos con la
presencia de sara castro directora del
diario hasta colombia para su análisis
bienvenidas ahora hola lo hizo un gusto
después de 28 años argentina vuelve a
ser campeón y lo hace en el maracaná con
eso ya arranca muy bien es interesante
ese dato y como bien lo apuntaba sahara
brasil y argentina- definieron el título
de la presente edición de la copa
américa
2021 siendo la cuarta vez en la historia
en la que ambos equipos se enfrentan
para dirimir al campeón de esta
confederación sudamericana de fútbol el
resultado fue favorable a la selección
de argentina con marcador de un gol por
cero el tanto de la victoria fue obra de
ángel di maría a los 22 minutos del
encuentro el gol además de darle triunfo
a la albiceleste significó la primera
victoria del combinado argentino en
brasil bajo una competición oficial
sara hace dos años revisaba algunos
medios argentinos y la selección era muy
criticada también criticaban a scaloni
quien venía
un interinato que ha sido permanente por
la actuación de la copa américa
2019 que cambio en la mentalidad de
scaloni y de los jugadores para hoy
estar alzando ese título estamos
hablando de una reconstrucción una
reconstrucción a partir del trabajo
argentina dejó de ganar de camiseta y
tuvo que aprender a sufrir y aprender a
jugar para messi sin que todas las
pelotas pasen por messi y eso
significaba un cambio muy importante uno
en el sistema de fútbol y también en la
manera como los jugadores interactúan
con uno de los mejores jugadores del
mundo había que reescribir la historia
una generación de jugadores se sintió
frustrada porque intentaban intentaban
nunca se conseguían los títulos y para
esto era necesario o fue bastante
polémico recurrir a un entrenador como
leonel scaloni que en teoría no tenía la
hoja de vida adecuada pero eso a partir
del trabajo donde este equipo empieza a
construirse y si bien llega la copa
américa aún con dudas a través de los
partidos empiezan a aparecer también
otras figuras hoy es muy diciente que el
entrenador apueste por ángel di maria
uno de esos compañeros de medidas
años que lucharon y lucharon por
conseguir este título en lugar de nico
gonzález es un jugador que le aportaba
mucho más tácticamente y son todos estos
jugadores que vieron una mención el
póster y que aprendieron a reconocerlo
como ídolo y ahora como compañero los
que logran esto sufrimiento orden
trabajo en la cancha un gol en una
llegada y luego aprovechar ese colectivo
hoy la figura es de paul rodrigo de paul
es absolutamente un partido espectacular
nicolás otamendi impasable en la defensa
y eso es lo que construye un equipo no
un jugador sino todo un colectivo
encaminado hacia el objetivo podemos
analizar brevemente a brasil que pasó
con un equipo que venía imbatible desde
la eliminatoria hasta esta final de copa
américa una vez más se ha salido del
circuito en la imagen cuando neymar no
encuentra compañeros con quién
digamos hacer circuito de juego se
complica mucho brasil y el tema es que
ti te ha venido probando un sistema de
juego que busca ser más competitivo que
lograr ese juego vistoso y eso
seguramente le va a acarrear muchas
críticas es un equipo que se está
preparando para el mundo
y que tal vez en este punto no encontró
con esos socios si ustedes ven neymar
deja de ser un delantero más y empieza a
ser un creador cuando no encuentra en
ese sistema jugadores con quien pasar la
pelota y no logran acelerar en las
transiciones ofensivas es muy difícil
que logren desequilibrar
vamos a ver cómo asume tanto la hinchada
brasilera como tite esta derrota en el
maracaná que siempre pone un punto un
punto más de dolor no un punto más para
la gestión del fracaso porque para ellos
era un fracaso pero sin duda es uno de
los mejores entrenadores del continente
insisto dependerá de la cbf y de todo el
sistema que lo acompaña como se respalda
este momento esta copa américa tuvo
muchas particularidades sobre todo
porque quizás no generó en el ambiente
esa fiesta que nos tiene acostumbrado un
evento de este tipo pero para conocer
más detalles de lo que fue esta final
veamos el siguiente reporte de nuestra
corresponsal en brasil- valeria sacó lea
no pudo ser ganar argentina pierde
brasil en el duelo entre messi neymar la
selección de messi se alza con su 15º
título ha alcanzado el mismo nivel de
títulos que tiene uruguay y brasil se
queda con nueve títulos además la
selección de brasil parece que ha
perdido su brillo desde aquel 71 contra
alemania en el mundial de 2014 no ha
vuelto a hacer lo que era muchas
personas en brasil y se quejan de que de
que es una selección identificada con la
cbf con la confederación brasileña del
fútbol acusada de corrupción y no con el
pueblo además la conmembol en general no
ha despertado muchas pasiones ha habido
muchos torneos en los últimos años la
eurocopa ha despertado más interés e
incluso la libertadores en general
despiertan más pasiones que esta copa
américa la reacción de los brasileños en
general y contrario a lo que se podría
pensar ha sido más bien fría y encima
las polémicas no han sido pocas el
estadio y estaba vacío porque por caso
de la pandemia el alcalde de río de
janeiro eduardo paes no quiso acceder a
las
y abrió en la forma 50% lo ha dejado en
el 10
hoy también supimos que algunas personas
acreditadas tanto de argentina como de
brasil tenía antes de la corona virus
falsos y eso ha generado también más
malestar pero bueno hoy es un día de
celebración para argentina y un día de
reflexión para brasil
situaciones extradeportivas que se
presentaron a lo largo de todo este mes
de fútbol
sara ya hablando en lo deportivo una
como américa muy atropellada pero que
vimos figuras emergentes en algunos
equipos caso la padula caso luís díaz en
colombia por ejemplo si hemos insistido
en este espacio que para los
entrenadores este es un periodo muy
importante para poder trabajar con
equipos que no habían podido tener
acceso no son esas unidades de trabajo y
aparecen esas dos figuras por ejemplo la
padula que era una apuesta
complicadísima un jugador para
reemplazar a la gran figura de perú como
es paolo guerrero jugador nacionalizado
que demostró que tiene muchísimos y muy
buenos registros en el ataque es una
jugador que siempre pone en problemas a
la defensa que está pensado de salir de
la zona insisto una de las grandes
figuras y por supuesto lo de luís díaz
hizo los golazos de la copa y demostró
que es uno de esos talentos emergentes
que tiene mucho potencial él ya está en
el puerto hizo parte de la selección
indígena de colombia hace muy poco era
sparring de la selección colombia y de
lo que hablas de eso de nuevos recursos
con los que cuentan estos entrenadores
entre ellos reinaldo rueda que además se
queda con este tercer lugar
en la copa américa nada despreciable
para un entrenador que apenas agarro el
equipo en este año y precisamente
hablando de luís díaz además de lionel
messi se quedaron con el hidrato de
coles de este torneo cuatro dianas para
cada uno y así de esta manera fueron los
referentes en este apartado por otro
lado la autora martínez y gianluca lapa
dura gritaron tres veces cada uno a lo
largo de toda esta competición pero en
otras notas de la copa américa
hay que mencionar que en el día de ayer
la selección de colombia quedó en el
tercer lugar luego de vencer a su
similar de perú en el partido disputado
en la ciudad de brasilia la selección
peruana había abierto el marcador a
través de yoshimar yotún a los 45 pero
el colombiano juan guillermo cuadrado
puso el empate a los 49 luís díaz anotó
el primero de sus dos goles a los 66 y
al huca lapadula empató a los 82 y luís
díaz cerró ya sobre el descuento
para colombia
el trabajo para el tercer lugar es
meritorio o sienta las bases para lo que
pudiese hacer algo más ambicioso en el
futuro son las bases pero es un gran
premio para el trabajo de reinaldo rueda
él no había logrado cerrar una gran
actuación en esta copa américa y creo
que ese gol en el último minuto
demuestra la lealtad y sobre todo el
compromiso que tienen estos jugadores
con esa nueva propuesta con un nuevo
proyecto deportivo que sin duda está
encaminados a la clasificación de qatar
en un partido interesante ambos equipos
jugaron bien pero mucho más directo
aprovechando las pocas oportunidades que
tuvo colombia le sigue faltando en lo
colectivo para lograr ser eficaz en el
área rival pero proceso yo creo que
vivimos dos equipos compitiendo además
dándole en el lugar que se merece a
estar compitiendo no seguir compitiendo
así sea para el tercer lugar creo que
ambos equipos dejaron todo en la cancha
a pesar además ya del cansancio que
tienen los jugadores en este momento del
torneo y sobre todo después de una larga
temporada a continuación una selección
de las principales noticias que no deja
que el presente torneo run actual
director técnico del fc barcelona abogó
por la
del argentino lionel messi con la causa
blaugrana bajo la importancia que tiene
no sólo para el club sino para la liga
española en general
messi actualmente está celebrando con la
selección argentina
de acuerdo con la agencia de noticias
efe que cita al vicepresidente del club
rey de bolivia el arquero de la
selección de ese país carlos lampe
habría acordado desvincularse de dicho
conjunto para jugar en argentina la
próxima temporada
de acuerdo con el medio peruano libro el
jugador de la selección de ese país
sergio peña habría despertado interés de
dos equipos de la liga de españa
actualmente el jugador forma parte del
himen de la segunda división de países
bajos
antes de despedirnos le recordamos que
mañana diario de copas cambiará
nuevamente de horario este domingo el
especial con motivo de la final de la
eurocopa que se llevará a cabo entre las
selecciones de inglaterra e italia será
sobre las 16 40 horas de bogotá lima y
quito allí estaremos analizando todos
los detalles que nos deja el máximo
torneo europeo muchísimas gracias ahora
por haber estado con nosotros esta noche
a todos ustedes gracias por acompañarnos
y los dejamos con más de la programación
de france 24 y france 24 en español
[Música]